Oh
we work on health as a human right we
bring together ministers of health and
try to support them in coping with the
many interventions on health by donor
governments by funds by the world health
organization etc i co-chair a high-level
body on the terrible brain drain of
health workers out of sub-saharan Africa
and out of parts of South Asia etc where
there's a high disease prevalence poor
health systems but the doctors and
nurses are leaving and coming to the
United States and parts of Europe and
how to make that fairer we work on
decent work one of the things about
African countries is the populations are
incredibly young in many of them well
over fifty percent of the population is
under 25 maybe under 20 and they have no
jobs so that's a human rights issue
you